I do wonder to myself sometimes how to
make an anime popular maybe all you need
to do is just make a show about ninjas
except take away everything ninja about
them and turn them into loud hyper and
watches kids who have the fashion sense
of a demented peacock or perhaps you
could read you the plot to Dragonball Z
of swords except owned under the
constipation and give all your female
characters enough collective boov masks
so they can seek the [ __ ] Titanic or
god forbid just do this to your show
the only thing for sure is that anime
certainly doesn't have to be good to be
popular and an anime that's good can be
very easily missed no anime fits this
case better than baka no and anime we
somehow missed the spotlight of 2007
since every time I tell something to
watch it I get a strange bordering look
like I'm some sort of release prick
cuz I'm apparently one of about ten
people have seen or heard of the show
baka most in 1930s America and circles
around a 3-way Train Robbery on the
train could the flying pussyfoot ah in
which all three groups are presumably
having a competition see you can grab it
because penis are the heads and from
their own [ __ ] hits the fan and we get
contender for the animated version of
the chaos theory but which one should we
do the wait I was wrong the show is
actually about war between two Mafia
families while a secret group of an auto
alchemist are attempting to remake the
lost secret of immortality or is
actually about Leo go look for a
[ __ ] brother yeah I forgot to
mention that the show is saying three
different timelines each told
simultaneously and somehow weaves all
three unrelated stories together anyway
as a testament on how well the show is
written the upload to these shows in the
first episode and the final climax
happens before the train even sets up so
in other words the beginning is the end
the end is the beginning the middle
she's [ __ ] off somewhere and
everyone's bloody confused and that's
the thing you will be confused watching
the series since the show moves fast
enough and enough things happened to
make this a 26-episode show but they
managed to squeeze everything it's just
13 episodes at first I was just so
confused and keeping up with everything
the show presented me with trying to
remember which character was in which
Mafia family which scene was in which
timeline which character the remote or
is this guy wearing green underwear or
red underwear but take my word for it
and just keep watching anyway because
all the small details don't matter in
the bigger picture and everything comes
together eventually in the end like me a
condom and two hours alone with your
mother there are so many characters in
this show that I could go on all day
describing them such as lad the
psychotic killer Vienna the psychotic
killer Cheney the not so psychotic was
still messed up killer and jacuzzi spot
yeah I know I mean he already has a
headstone having a stupid name and a
tattoo on his face which looks like it
was joined by a blind [ __ ] kid with
arthritis now they have to do to make
him a really annoying characters later
my warning and when crybaby who sounds
like Greg Harris with a cheese grater
attached to his voice
crying like a girl I could go on
describe you 16 plus characters that I
have blow words since they were all
likable in some way almost all like will
in some way so the only people I
mentioned is Isaac Maria a comic relief
characters whose every moment on screen
is pure gold and inherently are the two
most likeable characters I have ever
seen
why are you going my friend we are going
to hunt down the rail tracer we're going
to ask it very nicely to get off the
train
I've got to mention there's a mythical
creature called the rail tracer chasing
killing random passengers on the train
the Montford
real bird both died don't you worry
if things get ugly I'll use my trusty
hundred guns but you don't have any guns
how about that
but you know what a grizzled old ranch
and asked me once know where a real
cowboy gives his young his Hut
try not to die okay normally with the
show that has three storylines being
told simultaneously across the
characters too big to count and only
thirteen episodes the term [ __ ]
may be applied but Buckley achieved
something I thought he never could
achieve laughs we're finished watching
the first episode it clears out every
story that without too much confusion
somehow links more together it makes
every character like warm cool well
given those characters enough depth from
development that even jacuzzi spa
becomes likable in the end and makes it
so damn entertaining that's hard to find
a single minute that's boring seriously
this is a show that has everything great
action great comedy horror and god damn
even a bit of romance the show is
surprisingly Cory which isn't for
everyone but personally I thought I just
added to the whole fun of the show it's
Starla music give it a sense of coolness
that I haven't felt since watching
Cowboy Bebop
and I can't remember the last time I've
had so much fun with an anime it's one
of the Yaya animes I've seen which can
have the Laughing one second while
scared shitless next second while
getting me excited free action in the
next scene isn't that right that I would
recommend watching this anime dub since
you can hear all the New York accents
which while not perfect still help
immerse you in the show and make it feel
like you're watching a genuine 1930s
gangster movie or not just an anime the
main cast are all relatively unknown
which is a breath of fresh air from the
usual let's get one Lillian Michelle
rough the voice that we [ __ ] female
character under the Sun in the end Park
knows a series which no one should miss
because it is what every anime should be
pure untainted entertainment and it's a
shame that everyone's too busy
worshipping the hairy figurines and
tossing off to the newest definitely a
fanfiction that it showed you and get
more exposure as a cool is a style of
Cowboy Bebop the crazy characters you
find in the Guy Ritchie gangster flick
and a pulp fiction style of storytelling
they just have to watch to appreciate
top this off for one of the best anime
openings I've ever seen any have
yourself one hell of a show so you know
what I'm just gonna stop trying to
convince you to watch it and just tell
you - bloody watch it go on watch it
tell all your friends to watch it tell
your friends friends to watch it
give this anime the popularity and
deserves and make it so that any time I
try to recommend the show to someone I
don't get that same rewarded look on
their face followed by reply of in the
choir words of the Virgin Mary come
again I give this anime a well deserved
ten out of ten
you